if you go through life and you have this
expectation that you're gonna have the
wind at your back you're gonna be much
more disappointed then if you expect
there to be adversity headwinds friction
and flux and then you overcome it or
maybe it's not even there and so what
you worried about won't even occur so be
prepared expect that there's always
going to be resistance always is
resistance and the point I like to make
is you know imagine if you're imagine if
you're flying in California from San
Diego to San Francisco and it's 500
miles away and you've got a 100 mile an
hour tailwind going up there and then
you turn around and you might get a
hundred mile an hour headwind coming
back you're actually I spend more time
in the headwinds think about if there's
500 mile an hour headwind and your plane
goes 500 miles an hour you're not going
anywhere so you're gonna spend an
infinite amount of time in the headwind
enjoy the head with the headwind build
strength just like it does at the gym
when you have extra weight and friction
so enjoy the headwinds expect them and
then you'll be happy that you're
prepared if they happen and if